15 Chipotle has been on a roller coaster
business plummeted following a series of
foodborne illness outbreaks but
the workers think they have figured out
what made nearly 647 people sick at an
Ohio Chipotle food temperature
since 2008 Chipotle has had 10 scandals
regarding food poisoning which has
affected thousands of people spreading
diseases like hepatitis A norovirus E
coli salmonella and a clostridium
perfringence and those are just the
outbreaks that made it to the news many
of you probably know people who are food
poisoned after eating a Chipotle or
maybe it even happened to you yet
despite all these red flags Chipotle is
doing better than ever in the last 12
month period Chipotle brought an 8.4
billion dollars in revenue and it ended
up profiting it 800 million dollars
similarly they've expanded to over 3 000
locations across the U.S and it's not
just their fundamentals that have been
doing well either Chipotle stock has
also held up extraordinarily well
throughout the recession being down only
a mere 20 percent this pegs Chipotle's
valuation at 41 billion dollars which
are nearly a mixed that made top 10 food
brand in terms of market cap for
perspective that's over three times
larger than Domino's Pizza given their
popularity you would think that
addressing their food poisoning concerns
would be their top priority and
according to their PR it is but when we
look at the facts they don't look nearly
as favorable for Chipotles in fact it
actually looks like they're regressing
given that their outbreaks tend to
affect more people today for example
their first outbreak in 2008 affected 22
customers conversely in an outbreak in
2018 it ended up affecting it 700 people
first glance you might think that this
is somewhat expected for a China's
largest Chipotle when you're serving
that much food you're bound to serve
something that gets people sick but this
is actually not true McDonald's for
example has over 10 times the number of
locations all over the world yet their
Wikipedia page only mentions the word
outbreak once and the even that was in
the context of describing the
coronavirus outbreak conversely
Chipotle's Wikipedia page mentions the
word outbreak of whopping at 91 times
what makes this even more confusing is
that chipotle uses much of the same food
supply chain as McDonald's so what in
the world is going on at Chipotle and
why do so many people choose to eat
there anyway
foreign
to understand what's going wrong at
Chipotle we first have to take a look at
their origin because there was a point
in time when Chipotle wasn't synonymous
with food poisoning granted it's been
quite some time the story of Chipotle
dates back to 1993 to a man named Steve
Ells Steve was a classically trained
Chef who had a few years of experience
working in the traditional restaurant
industry as a sous chef while this Giga
gave Steve some experience he knew from
day one that he wanted to open a fine
dining restaurant jumping to that from
just being a sous chef was quite a leap
though so at age 28 Steve borrowed 85
000 from his friends and family and
opened a small burrito shop instead in
Denver Colorado initially he estimated
that he needed to sell at least 107
burritos per day to be profitable but he
ended up crushing this number by the end
of the first month itself Steve was
selling over a thousand burritos per day
this strong reception gave Steve the
confidence to take out an SBA loan and
open additional restaurants in Colorado
we can't give Steve all the credit
though as he had substantial help from
his father you see it Steve's father was
a wealthy pharmaceutical executive and
while he was hesitant to invest at
Ground Zero once he saw these results he
became a mass investor putting in 1.5
million dollars despite having access to
all this Capital Steve was in no rush to
open up a bunch of restaurants or expand
the outside of the state for two reasons
for one Steve strongly believed in
keeping the business simple and
straightforward and that this is very
much a core principle of Chipotle to
this day I mean this is basically their
entire menu in the tour turning Chipotle
into a nationwide giant wasn't never
Steve's Vision his goal was to Simply
get some experience running Chipotle
before switching over to fine dining but
by 1998 it was becoming an extremely
difficult to stick to this original
Vision simply due to how well Chipotle
was doing instead of resisting it Steve
would simply embrace the change and to
go all in on Chipotle opening their
first restaurant outside of Colorado
1998. now that chipotle was no longer
just a local sensation bigger investors
would become interested particularly
McDonald's MacDonald started off with a
small steak but they would end up making
Chipotle into who they are today over
the next seven years McDonald's helped
Chipotle grow from 16 locations to over
500 locations by investing a whopping
360 million dollars which gave them a 90
stake in the company but money wasn't
even the biggest asset that McDonald's
brought to the table their primary
contribution was of course their
experience while McDonald's gets a bad
rep for selling highly processed junk
food one thing you can't argue with is
that they're exceptional at selling set
of food they've honed in everything from
marketing and franchising to the supply
chain and food safety and this expertise
was very much evident in Chipotle's
Flawless growth from 16 stores to 5 500
stores but unfortunately for Chipotle
McDonald's would not stick around
forever
while McDonald's was crushing it with
Chipotle the same could not be said
about their own business during the.com
crash McDonald's dock would sell off at
75 and it would take them at eight years
to return to their former Heights while
much of this was simply due to the state
of the economy McDonald's Executives
decided that they had to stop spending
so much effort on relatively small
Investments like Chipotle and instead of
focus on their own growth so in 2006
they decided to take Chipotle public and
sell off their entire State despite all
the selling pressure Chipotle went on to
have an extremely successful IPO before
going public Chipotle actually raised
their IPO price twice but even with that
chipotle ended up rocketing 100 during
their first day as a public company this
made Chipotle's second the best
restaurant IPO since the.com crash this
strong support from investors made it
seem like Chipotle would have a smooth
timing even without McDonald's
but almost immediately you could see the
consequences just two years after
McDonald's left Chipotle would have
their first notable Health crisis in
March of 2008 a Chipotle location in La
Mesa California would be linked to 22
cases of hepatitis A just one month
later Chipotle would have yet another
outbreak this time the disease was
norovirus and it ended up infecting 440
people so what in the world happened
within these 24 months well one of the
most notable points was Chipotle's
stranded towards decentralization I
don't think you'd be surprised to hear
that McDonald's was a strong proponent
of centralized operations virtually all
of their ingredients come from Mass
Distributors like Keystone Foods every
year Keystone Foods alone delivers 150
million pounds of beef 300 million
pounds of chicken and the 15 million
pounds of fish to McDonald's while this
type of supply chain raises a lot of
questions regarding animal treatment
preservatives and the GMOs one one thing
that's not in question is consistency
when all of your food comes from one
location it's all gonna be the same more
importantly though a simplified supply
chain makes it easier to maintain
quality and identify issues quickly
given that much of Chipotle's entire
brand is built around Simplicity you
would think that Steve would stick to a
centralized supply chain but he actually
had other plans do you see it Steve had
caught sense of a larger food Trend
which pushed people to ditch junk food
and eat healthier being an opportunistic
businessman Steve decided to jump onto
this trend of producing quote-unquote
organic locally sourced food looking
packet this was a perfect choice in
terms of their marketing and branding it
and it's also the ethical choice this
turned out to be a nightmare in terms of
quality control
foreign
tries to source as many ingredients as
possible from within a 350 mile radius
while this locally grown produce idea
sounds great on paper there is a reason
that Mega food corporations shy away
from this idea it's because it's
virtually impossible to maintain
standards across thousands of suppliers
and chipotle would figure this out the
hard way it is a decentralized supplies
Channel also put a lot of strand on
Chipotle stores because their stores
were built to operate in the exact
opposite manner with Simplicity Chipotle
locations don't have any freezers
microwaves or even can openers this
means that the staff have to take on a
lot of responsibility when it comes to
Preparing the food given that it's a
restaurant you would think that this
would be a given but it's not most fast
food places structure their business
such that fast food workers don't have
to do much preparation basically
everything comes pre-made meaning that
the workers simply have to heat up the
food or assemble it Chipotle workers on
the other hand are literally given raw
ingredients I mean they literally make
their food in front of you this would be
okay if we were talking about an actual
sit down restaurant filled with
experienced staff but most Chipotle
locations are run by young adults and
high school students so there is a
massive learning curve in 2015 and 2016
it during the worst of Chipotle's
outbreaks Chipotle actually spent a lot
of effort on strengthening their
training programs but this quickly LED
them to yet another issue employee
turnover just as employees start to get
the hang of things they leave in 2021
Chipotle's turnover rate was 194 this
means that the average employee barely
sticks around for four months which is
not that surprising given that it's a
near minimum wage job Chipotle has tried
to combat this by handing out a cash and
stock bonuses offering maternity slash
paternity coverage and even offering
life insurance and short-term disability
but none of this can contains the
fundamental fact that in the end it's
still a fast food job and this is really
the story of Chipotle as a whole they're
trying to do all these great things like
sourcing local food and promoting
healthier options but there is still a
fast food place and they have to deal
with all of the limitations that come
along with that and these issues are
only made worse by seemingly negligent
leadership while Steve started Chipotle
with a great passion for food it seems
that over the years it yes become much
more interested in the money in fact
Chipotle is Infamous for paying their
Executives ridiculous sums of money back
in their early 2010s Chipotle paid out
300 million dollars to their co-ceos
these guys were earning Fang CEO type
salaries even though Chipotle was
pulling in less than one percent of the
revenue of companies like Apple or
Google not to mention it their profit
margins were way lower as well
shareholders did eventually put their
foot down it and refused to prove such
compensation packages
but this just goes to show where the
executor's priorities really were
[Music]
considering all this why in the world do
people continue to eat at Chipotle well
the answer is simple as this core user
puts it Chipotle actually serves real
food or at least real hard food than
other fast food joints real food it
comes with real flavors that create a
unique appeal but they also come with
real risk the only way to avoid this
risk is to cook yourself spend a fortune
on eating out or eat highly processed
Bland foods and a given that most people
are one too lazy to cook themselves two
not rich enough to eat out at 5 star
restaurants regularly and three want
something more than McDonald's or Burger
King junk they flocked something in the
middle which just so happens to be
Chipotle so Chipotle's greatest strength
is also their biggest weakness and they
only have two options moving forward
they can re-centralize like the Legacy
competition or they can try to fix what
they already have now to clear which
side Chipotle has chosen and looking at
their fundamentals and it's working out
just fine are you a fan of Chipotle
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're a fan of real food and of
course consider checking out our Discord
Community such as video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions that logically answered until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]